字幕: Tomoko Hori
校正: Moe Shoji
私の強みは聞こえないこと
何にも聞こえていません
［強みは聞こえないこと］
今ここは音楽が流れているの？
今ここは静かなの？
そんなことも 私にはわかりません
でも私は この音のない世界から
見えてくるものを
楽しんでいます
小学校４年で
右耳が聞こえなくなり
高校２年生で
左耳も聞こえなくなりました
両耳とも音を失って27年
今 自分が出している
声の大きさも分かりません
皆さんに私の声は届いていますか？
ありがとうございます
皆さんは人と人とのコミュニケーションを
楽しんでいますか？
私はいつでも誰とでも
コミュニケーションを楽しんでいます
［コミュニケーションを楽しんでる？］
もし皆さんが 私と違うと言ったら
それはきっと
音声だけしか使ってないから
ではないでしょうか
［コミュニケーション＝音声だけ？］
私のコミュニケーションは
音声のほか―
手話
筆談
空間に書いたり
音声認識のアプリを使ったり
口の形を読み取ったり
それから 顔の表情
例えば 眉毛の上げ下げ
眉間のしわ
目を大きく見開いたり 細めたり
頬の動きとか 首の傾け方
体の動作や動き 呼吸など
全部で15種類以上もあると思います
もっとあるかもしれません
これだけたくさんあると
コミュニケーションも
わくわくすると思いませんか？
音声に頼らないって自由なんです
私は耳が聞こえません
でもきっと皆さんよりも
コミュニケーションを楽しんでいますよね
そして私は 必ず相手の目を見ます
私にとってのコミュニケーションは
すべて目で捉えているのです
見えることも大切なんです
目と目を合わせることから
すべてが始まります
［目と目を合わせることから］
私は自分のコミュニケーションを
「対話」と呼んでいます
対話とは元々
「２人の人が向き合って話をする」
それだけの意味です
でも私にとっての対話は
少し違います
まず目と目を合わせ
お互いの思いや価値観を
言葉にして紡ぐことで
お互いの言葉が響き合い
そこから生まれる思いを分かち合い
自分を そして相手を信頼する
深いつながりを作っていくこと
これが私にとっての「対話」です
向き合って話をするだけではなくて
相手を見て 強い信頼関係を作っていく
このプロセスすべてなのです
［対話：強い信頼関係を作り上げる
プロセスすべて］
私にとって聴覚を失うとは
耳で聞いて 声で話すという
会話の手段を失うことと
人とのつながりも失う
ということでした
私は聞こえていたいのに
音がどんどん遠ざかっていきます
砂浜の砂をすくってもすくっても
指の間からさらさらと
零れ落ちていくように
風の音も 音楽も
弟や妹の笑い声も
少しずつ消えていきました
そして両親が私の名前を呼ぶ声も
皆さん 想像してみてください
自分の名前が呼ばれても
聞こえないのです
もう私は 誰からも
「果林」と呼ばれても
聞くことはできないんです
もう二度と
みんなが笑っているのに
私だけ分からない
何を話しているの？
何が面白いの？
全く聞こえない
誰も信じられない
聞こえていた自分がいなくなり
残されたのは 音を失った自分
だけど それでも
誰かとつながりたい
つながりたいのに
つながることができない寂しさ
冷たい湖の底にひとりで沈んで
静かな孤独感がありました
そこから感じる気持ちや思いを
文字にして書くことにしました
こちらは 私が中学生の時の担任の先生と
やり取りをした生活ノートです
［「文字」でつなぎとめる
中学時代生活ノート９冊］
心の中にあるモヤモヤや
言葉にできない思いを
たくさん書いていました
どんなことを書いても受け止めて
返事を書いてくれる先生とのつながりが
たまらなく嬉しかった
高校生になっても日記を書くことで
文字にして書くことを続けていきました
どうしたって
つながりたい私がいたのです
相手の言っていることを知りたい
つながりたい
信じたい
この思いが 今 私が
誰とでも楽しく対話をしたいと
つながりたいと思う原点です
知りたい つながりたい 信じたい
［知りたい つながりたい 信じたい］
高校を卒業した後
私は大学に入って初めて
自分以外の聴覚障がい者と出会い
音のない世界でもコミュニケーションが
できることを知りました
そして 誰もが一緒に楽しむための
ユニバーサルデザインという考え方を知り
それをライフワークとして
結婚 出産
子育ても20年
ひと段落 着いたところです
今では聞こえない人生を
楽しんでいる私ですが
そんな私にも 「聞こえたい」って
思ったことが 一度だけあります
それは 子供が産まれた時
生まれて初めて泣いた時
生まれて初めて笑った時
生まれて初めて声を出した時
私は「聞こえたい」って 思いました
３分でいいから
聞こえたのなら
その声を記憶として刻み込み
一生忘れないのにって 思いました
私はぎゅっと抱きしめて
その声を全身で感じ取りました
私の思いを全身で伝えてきました
だから今も私は 全身で
対話をしたいと思っています
３年前 日本で初めて
音のない世界で言葉の壁を超えて
楽しむエンターテイメント
ダイアログ・イン・サイレンスが
開催されました
［ダイアログ・イン・サイレンス］
［音のない世界で言葉の壁を超える
エンターテインメント］
音を遮断する
特別なヘッドセットをつけて
聴こえる人も 聴こえない人も
外国人も 大人も子供も
一緒に言葉を使わずに
顔の表情やボディーランゲージで
対話をするのです
聴こえる皆さんが
音のない世界で対話をすると
どうなると思いますか？
その空間を案内するのが
私と同じ聴覚障がいのある人たちです
私は３年間で
１万人のお客様を見てきました
私がお客様を見ると
お客様も私を見ます
私が微笑むと
お客様も微笑んでくれます
私が視線を移動させると
お客様も同じものを見ようとします
私がボディーランゲージで伝えると
お客様も一緒についてきてくれます
同じようにお客様も ボディーランゲージで
伝えてくれようとするのです
最初は緊張していて
体が固まっている人とか
無表情だった人たちが
目を合わせることができるようになり
背が伸びて 脚が伸びて
いろいろな動きができることを
体が思い出したようにして
体全部で伝えてくれるようになるのです
そう いつも私が
楽しんでいる対話と同じように
こちらは
［ふつーがよかった］
私が音を失いつつある時の日記です
「ふつうがよかった
ふつうがよかった」
「どうかどうか
きこえるようになりますように」
この言葉を 何度も何度も
書いていました
聴こえてさえいれば
誰とでも話ができる
誰とでもつながれる
でも 聴こえるとか聴こえないが
対話の本質ではないのです
［聞こえることが対話の本質ではない］
まず目と目を合わせて
お互いの思いや価値観を言葉にして
全身で伝えることで
強い信頼関係を作っていく
プロセスすべてなのです
それが お互いにとって
心地よく もっと対話を
重ねていきたいと思えるものです
［お互いに心地よく もっと対話を
重ねていきたいと思えるもの］
今日はたくさんの人が集まっています
この後 皆さんは初めて会う色んな人と
まず目を合わせてみてください
そこから対話が始まります
あなたは今日 誰と目を合わせますか？
ありがとうございました
（笑）（拍手）